and is going to show you Walton here we
go
wall jump and that's really useful if
peoples are running behind you you can
do side jump just little sides off with
a jump back like this and it is spins
and use the jump back wall this prince
is going to increase his inertia assault
is a very powerful class if you know how
to use you very agile and if you have
open space it's as you use this class
inside a building like inside a building
to compare to a headlock or Devastator
he's actually oh yeah ah did you get it
uh no nice right there right there hey
run for your life because he's trying to
go underneath yes here we go
boy hundred XP see that was that's the
type of tactics that as an assault is
very powerful with but again meeting a
Devastator inside of a building then it
is the other way around a Devastator as
a very high powerful heavy bolter you
can switch a different type of weapon
you can even have a last cannon the last
cannon is an extremely powerful weapon
it has a telltale sign when you use it
you're committed to using it and you're
kind of vulnerable when you're using it
but it's a one shot on on people and it
doesn't take much to actually kill a
vehicle and if you use it too much often
like on the tabletop it heats up so you
have to be careful using that and one
other thing that I would like Oliver to
show you before our when he gets inside
is with the heavy bolter so if you try
to shoot without moving but just to
shoot straight you'll see that it's
really enough besides and don't control
the recoil so if it doesn't control the
recoil you see the
the mythical is bacon is going up but
now if he does the same thing but he put
an e on the floor if he puts an e on the
floor
crouching and he shoots is bracing
himself and the ripple is more precise
one other thing I want other a liver to
show you is when you can brace uncut on
the cover is is a V bolter here we go so
he's going to crouch behind it obviously
have a bolter and now he's going to
brace it like a turret so basically now
he has no recoil Westover look very very
small one and is under cover on top of
that and so when you're protecting a
capture point and you're in this
position you're very very hard to to
unchanged so what you see now is the
real space frnd you look at this
animation roll this is all mocap by a
very very good more cap actor don't
shoot him don't shoot him
please okay good oh yeah it's new
execution animation as well so all that
this by the way is very exclusive it
you're the only you're the first one to
show this and so you see the Crouch how
is the difference it is and you see how
he turns this is all mocap and I is
going to show you a the load up menu
which is not functional yet but it's
just to show you that again that's a
very very early I think the first
implementation of this was last week so
you can see the different loadout that
you can select so as an example if
you're a tactical Space Marine sorry
assault space premiere you can give away
your jump pack to have a strong shield
instead of a jump pack so again is to
change the game mechanic and in the way
it works is really the same as when you
play tabletop game you decide on a
thousand point game so your loadout will
have a maximum of points that you can
load onto it
and then that's again to put in the
asymmetric balance oh yeah one other
thing I want to show you you see right
now Oliver is using is mass so the UI
change automatically so right now he has
a
a gamepad UI and if I move the mouse if
you stop touching it if I just move the
mouse you see it's changing for a mouse
and keyboard loadout and if you it's
charging back to a gamepad loadout and
that's because we have the license we're
releasing the game announced for PC and
Macintosh but we're gonna we have the
license for ps4 and Xbox one and right
now when this our VP of business
development is meaning what Sony and
Microsoft to discuss the business deal
to have our game run on these metrics
next-gen platform